alright guys just gonna say straight up
all your fears all of a high all the
kids are everything you have about it
you can put it to rest
Fernan and is delightful I wouldn't
think that John Cena can carry a movie
but he's he's really good yeah we're
gonna have to agree to disagree
yeah cuz yeah it was a little too Star
Wars II for me you think so I thought
the minute I saw this I said ma'am
that's that's a bunch of bull okay let's
get right to it
first off spoiler alert Luke is his own
father yeah he had an argument with
himself it was great yeah that's not
true that's impossible
search my feelings okay he's just threw
himself off the okay so just straight up
we're not gonna have spoilers at the
beginning we'll go into them a little
bit later but we may have to take them I
love whatever I say here the light is
like reflecting perfectly off my head so
I look like ball Jesus oh but you really
don't care about that only time we're
going to have the words you and Jesus
not ball
so speaking of space Jesus Luke yes okay
so like I said we won't get into
spoilers we'll just say real fast what
we thought this movie um I really liked
it yeah my first my first initial fear
was that it was gonna be Empire Strikes
Back again and slightly but way
different enough that you wouldn't even
know I don't know if it's appropriate or
not to quote George Lucas on this but
when he was making the prequels Jar Jar
is the key that was the quote you got it
I know he said something that I don't I
doubt he originated because it's so good
but maybe he did uh he said I don't like
to repeat I like scenes to rhyme I like
elements to rhyme and in the FIR in
force awakens granted I got why but
there was a lot of repeating of a new
hope and even though there was a 50-50
suite of repeating and rhyming and yeah
rhyming the repeating like you know just
second yeah this felt like this felt
like rhyming this felt like we have
evolved to a new spot the characters
have come a long way there where they
should be there's almost another mythos
being developed while there's also a
Smith O's there that we're finding out
more and more about and we I feel like
it's Deval so finally putting the past
mythos all of Lucas's rhymes kind of in
a box and going we're gonna be done with
this now we think like in many respects
they destroy rate once and for all when
you really think about it but we'll get
to that yeah you know this is the first
the first time in in a Star Wars movie I
mean since the probably Empire were I
felt like I'm seeing something new yeah
like that really it was like new and for
the first time since Empire I'm like I'm
seeing something challenging like this
movement like it's not a haha is in this
fun movie it's it's kind of challenging
you kind of leave the cinema going huh
even if you have nothing who would have
thought Star Wars would be a challenging
movie yeah Empire I think for a lot of
people it was a little trip that's the
closest to challenge about space yeah
honestly my place I think this is a
little more challenging vampire the some
of the things you like really we're
trying to be challenging but it doesn't
work but you're just to say the basic
story advanced I love it is kind of
challenging but it doesn't succeed this
succeeds and it's interesting and it
feels big and grant you feel like you
just watched a trilogy in this one film
go all out this is like my oh I served
you right when the end credits rolled I
was like why just feel like the trilogy
ended right there yeah there's another
movie like you kinda take the Bradley
okay
in terms of stuff I didn't like again I
won't get into too many spoilers the
stuff I don't like I feel is again kind
of nitpicky light like nothing too bad
but there is one main
very side-quests very site query Legend
of Zelda like just every second you
think something's gonna happen like is
is like and now we need to do this thing
get to it link like yes it's not and
it's not I can't see it's bad it's right
movie yeah it's not bad but okay this
can we get through this so we get it
back to Luke and rain there's a slick
one set a casino that just feels like
it's in a whole different movie it goes
Casino Royale all of a sudden and it's
the first time that I felt kind of like
I'm like this feels almost prequel
territory to foreign and now it's both
few felt for into Star Wars and it felt
kind of like the way the prequels just
had the 50s diner yeah my well that's
why I said well that's Indies diner
scene it's just they changed a few yeah
ii didn't make it quite as bright but
it's like yeah it's just you look at
well that's a casino where i felt like
there's not as obnoxious as that seem
but i'm just like this does not fit with
the rest of the movie I feel like in in
the first Star Wars when they go to moss
eisely and they go in the cantina well
that's a bar you give that but if you
were to see electric lights if you to
see little advertisements if you were to
see like bottles and but they didn't
really do that they're kind of these
weird glasses there was a weird if you
look aronia ads or Corona sketch there's
no ads in this but you just looking it's
like okay make change they have been put
some aliens and sass like that too
oh and they made the suits a little odd
yeah store there is not alien Sun like
the the cantina jazz scene sounds just a
lien enough we're just like yeah oh it's
jazzy but it feels in the other world
this one I was just like this is just a
1920s jazz kind of thing going on is we
hope it felt otherworldly this felt
y-yeah aliens in the casino um so yeah
that was the biggest thing to me that
stuck out like a sore thumb and
generally the whole if if it's ray and
Luke it was fine yes and
ever cuts away it just all of the side
quests and stuff didn't have that same
sense of Drive I got a little bored
words when I think of Empire I'm like no
when you cut to Han and Leia and Chewie
all running away it's grade them on
Cloud City still great them hiding yeah
and there's being trained by Yoda
great every single thing worked and then
this one it's very much like ray and
Luke great this other stuff anywhere
from what - okay - all right that's
pretty good like but it's never like got
that same Drive its to count and even
with an empire with Han Solo and Leia
and stuff you know trying to get away
it's still them trying to get away from
Darth Vader though those are all such
interesting characters and you're
introduced to a new character who isn't
bad really like there yeah a lot might
take two because she didn't suffer from
the Star Wars but you don't see where
it's like the other Solo and Leia and
Chewie and stuff where is this way it's
Finn and this other woman and they're
supplying there's not like that and it's
like okay we're not getting like a
Harrison Ford or it's just like you know
she's kind of like Finn she's like
here's another person who just you know
works on some shit down in the lower
decks yeah I don't know that no I mean
it's one of those things but they send
them on our overly complicated I just I
get kind of like a little like Oh cousin
Empire you're you're stuck on the ship
with them but they're so interesting and
then hear it and then they go to Cloud
City and claw City is so interesting
here it's like okay they're traveling to
this place that's a casino and you're
there for a while it's not okay oh it's
this story about like you know that the
past and how they treat the people here
and stuff like that it's like I feel
that ties together and it comes together
at the end like the production design of
it nobody but you know what I mean where
it's like okay sucks there's kind of all
this other shit going on that's really
important I it's kind of of it the
essence but I think her hate but it
doesn't feel as
urge when you seven a soul on the small
stuff when you're willing to do that you
it has bigger facts you know she's on an
entire planet that basically they're
just selling their souls to basically
fund the war machine and get rich off it
so I and I think that's an important
lesson particularly if you're starting
to rebuild this mythos and say hey you
know look at how the world is yeah yeah
it but yeah it just there was too much
just do this do that do that do this I
liked how the casino scene ended yeah
now we're gonna sneak kind of start the
story now we got to do this and it's a
slow build eventually it starts coming
together when it does I'm like oh it's
real we're okay but it just takes a
while to get there and yeah this is a
hot movie because there's kind of two
climaxes almost to this like I had to
remind myself
oh yeah there's like gotta be another
half hour of this movie laughs cuz
something in the translation where it
has to go a movie bubbles a couple of
like fast ones on you and I thought oh
we're done and then when we got to the
climate so it oh yeah forgot about this
at the same time I was excited to see I
know it's kind of the feeling I got when
I used to watch James Cameron movies
where it's like there is almost like
another ending but instead be like ah
geez are we still going it's like yes
Avengers where it looks like oh it's
just getting with hold punching that
thing and then they're gonna die but no
even more of those things come through
and you're excited and that's what I got
with this you feel like yes oh my god
like everything's kind of been building
up to this is your whiskey and it really
delivers it's very rogue one it's better
than we're gone devil II but it has that
same issue of like the first half you're
kind of plodding through it and then all
of a sudden somewhere it just clicks and
you're just like how was I not thinking
like an hour goes I seen the greatest
movie ever my disagree a little bit
because rogue one did not have anything
as good as the Luke of racing's I
thought no every time they watch agreed
it was solid and it was and it was that
other but the difference and not just
was pace it would just felt like
sometimes it would just randomly cut
away with those Star Wars wipes
well yeah but again I wish it was just
on them but he wished it would actually
go all the way of just have it on Ben
it killed the momentum so much fun as I
had with those scenes I would just kind
of go ah like I was enjoying that like
cut back to you like and then so those
are still really solid and I think both
of them are are so good at Hamel
especially I mean we haven't seen him
like act act you know I mean he was a
brilliant voice acting but we have seen
on screen when it's great because the
actor because we know now it says that
old gravelly like Mark Hamill voice if
it's coming out of Luke Skywalker and
I'm like and you really did become
badass didn't you yeah no and it's great
and he-man
I you know again when we can't go into
the climax of this but yeah like you
said they do pull up your fast ones that
didn't I don't know it didn't like shock
shock me but I didn't see it coming
they're like Mary there no that's like a
few minutes before it happens it's like
okay they're probably gonna do this
there were that there was no twist there
was what the there were there were two
twists that kind of got me and I'd have
to go in the spoiler corner but for that
but for mojo mind blown yeah for most of
the movie there were no twists that I
couldn't have been like okay that was
one of like three options I was thinking
out there was nothing that I was like oh
my god whatever I'm like I can't believe
they did that
yeah but it still felt kind of
challenging because I wouldn't have
expected them coming off the Abrams film
necessarily to do that yeah cuz Abram
was playing it more safer well I think
because not only do they make these
choices but they also shot it's so grand
and there's quiet moments and there's
moments where they don't need to talk in
just the menus that can take over and it
really is brave enough to do that where
Lobby blockbusters aren't and again I
think that's really reinforced what the
force awakens needed to kind of it's not
easily cook it's not easy answers I
think a lot of people are gonna leave
the cinema going but I had this image of
these characters and you know it's now I
feel like it's kind of selling on them a
bit like it it kind of removes the the
whole point of the film I think is to
kind of remove that sense of like legend
like you know maybe you shouldn't
Messiah worship hmm to such a degree and
it's about like kind of seeing the man
behind the curtain
particularly with
well and again they do it felt so
organic the way it was sort of passing
on from one generation to a next and how
they did and the connections are still
there and again the rhymes not
necessarily the repeats that go through
it and much more in this one there's
like scenes that have that return to the
Jedi Emperor talking to oh yeah and
twists and turns there and you just feel
like it's like I somehow have seen this
before but this feels fresh yeah yeah
it just felt much more fresher in this
and I think in force awakens it doesn't
feel like they're looking and winking at
the care at we said that line see yeah
much more like no this is what would
naturally happen yeah and it's earned
and it built up to those points you know
and so that we do get to the climax and
it's shot beautifully it looks
beautifully and here's all these
characters doing just grant huge things
it all feels like this is exactly where
we should be this is the next step that
Star Wars should be taking so I'm very
very happy I think that I think my
favorite scene was um I don't think its
Empire Strikes Back ish so the rebellion
keeps getting beat back further and
further and further and just when it's
just like that the handful of everybody
left and it's just like well this is it
like what are we gonna do and they like
start unpacking their shit like we're a
fucking setup and fine I like I love
that scene like just what a great
message just like just resist just keep
going and they they didn't even blink it
was like they were unpacking their
laptops like setting up a new base I
love that I think that was my favorite
scene in the movie and then just Mark
Hamill gives a sly wink and it's just so
perfect
yeah it's it's it's just really really
good guys I'm at the finale was gorgeous
that the finale is shot literally like a
Western and it's like High Noon like a
Western with robots yeah a Western with
giant robots and there's like there's
like the Sun setting it's like a red sky
it's like a dusty barren like it's just
I'm just like wow this feels both really
epic which is what I did like about
force awakens the the battle between
kylo Ren and Rey and the forest of the
way that the canyons split and I love
that animals like this they kind of do
it again but it again it feels fresh it
looks really cool and it's a weird mix
of what like kind of Lucas had in mind
originally which is it's about this epic
space sword thing but also just kind of
a Western lion again it's literally
boils down it looks like a really good
anime yeah it boils down to what Star
Wars related the heart really is it's
all this sci-fi all this giant
technology and stuff but when you boil
down to it it's just this little
family's quarrel at the end and that's
really what it comes down to you know I
get wonderfully to my guy but fine this
guy's gets it like he really gets like
Lucas too and and courser done Empire
where it's just like it's always about
this image of like two people swords
drawn staring at each other that's the
part of Star Wars and I've the space
battles to do but that's the part about
Star Wars
I just love when they like face off each
other I'm like yeah shit's getting real
this might be my favorite looking of
them too
not necessarily of like you know keeps
you thinking like the casino and stuff
that's not very man-to-man there's one
or two creatures I would've gotten
really good looking at get really good
slow build you know what it is when when
it was operatic that's what I'm like
this is yeah this is what there's so
many shots of people just looking at the
sunset there's so many shots of people
just looking in silence there's so many
like incredible moments where either the
scenery does the talking or just the
character sitting alone you know
thinking about everything that's going
on does the talking you know and even
with that said some of the dialogue just
those short quick little lines that
aren't many words but they packed such a
punch I mean I think Star Wars was also
great at and again the prequels didn't
do they talked way too much went on and
on and on this really you doesn't like
the debates about taxation in the
trademarks outside of
no no girlfriends I also like to there
is still comedy in this but we're again
I feel like in the first one you had to
really sort Drive in the comedy it was
good and it's funny you know Disney
especially it's just really on board
I've really on top of their comedy and
this has funny moments but it's really
like not let's not put them in when
they're not needed let's really let the
drama set in the comedy was a little in
some parts particularly near the end I
thought really really worked and they
were there a few comedic scenes are
missing that's kind of died but it
didn't I was like it wasn't offensively
bad and it wasn't yeah it I'm trying to
think if it was one line that stuck out
is really funny that really worked but I
oh maybe we don't give it away yeah but
there's Hamill has a very funny Hamill's
got a lot kind of read of all people I
think as a couple yeah but one past
character who comes back it has some
really not just funny but very poignant
life they will get today when we get to
that so yeah point you by the way Carrie
Fisher in this movie whole performance
beautiful irony yeah there was like one
scene there there I was like fine
throughout most of movie but near the
end there's like when it was getting
there Dan there was one scene where I'm
just like don't do this to me movie this
it's like all about goodbyes that the
one is he I was a little ready for that
even though there was a real powerhouse
but again when this other character
comes back that was the one that was
like so it's okay so bottom line I'm
trying to think anything else before
going to spoiler territory that's like
that we need to address I mean I don't
think sizes this is the first Star Wars
film that I feel like is I actually
challenged me to be like oh maybe we
need to actually start like rethinking
what Star Wars is maybe it's becoming
something new again
fresh but not in the crummy way yeah
it's no it's not it's not an easy movie
and people who leave this going I don't
know I would get that I'm not gonna sit
here and be like what the hell's
of you but it I really enjoyed it but
it's I can't even talk about it that
much because I feel like I need to see
the second time don't you feels the
closest to after the original trilogy
came out that they wrote these books and
that they were you know continuing the
story it does have an expanded it really
has that feel because I really like even
goats but yeah it feels like this is
where we're hitting notes to familiarize
yourself but we're also doing our own
thing of course we just brought up the
expanded universe now we're gonna have a
thousand people getting into fights
about whatever you know did pick your
poison or whatever but ya know it's um
this is really what I wanted to see in
another Star Wars movie and I you know I
like Star Wars fine I snoke's a little
better snow looks so much better does he
don't my god does he look but we'll talk
in this way I why could they do make dog
what is it yeah why comply and what
they're good what's going on with the
Hugh Hefner thing hello smoking jacket I
wanted to have a pipe there yeah
Martinez heads like welcome to my
Imperial bachelor pad like it hey babe I
know yeah I don't want to get into
spoilers but like his his hope it's all
done in red this salt-free red color and
that set is gorgeous no it's gorgeous
but with a button that his outfits
really weird yeah red color did I just
feel like is like is this like the
Imperial grotto watching with the
remotely cocina The Big Lebowski
yeah sorry Snoke I still jerk off man
you're so but anywho on the digital age
dude
and so I very much enjoy isn't perfect
particularly in the first third there
are slow moments and continually of the
cyclists and the pinky moments that me
that will give it like you know it's
just we're gonna have to accept it at
some point lightnings got not gonna
strike twice
you know the line the original star well
yeah and I mean that I think the line I
think the line from Family Guy is just
gonna sum up everything from here I know
which is what can I say Peter it's not
empire like you know we had that one
that just seemed everything clicked
we're never really going to get that
back like it's it's engrained in our
brains and everybody says I just want
that back I want something like yes and
that's what I like about this it may be
imperfect but I was like I feel like
we're going into some slightly different
we're going somewhere we're not going
yet back and we're not going back in
doing it worse and we're not going to
this direction that's like wait what
we're even are we this is Star Wars it
feels like no we are going somewhere I'm
excited to get there so yes so that
that's our thoughts you know if you're a
star Wars fan you're gonna go see yeah
yeah yeah yeah definitely so okay let's
go into spoiler territory where do we
even start
what's really weird to me okay now that
we're in sport okay I thought they were
gonna kill her right there everybody did
she disappeared they would have cut to
her body floating in space I'm like okay
because I'm like I'm like maybe this is
gonna well when her finger started
moving here's what I thought was gonna I
was like that's not communicate with ya
I thought she could communicate with
Luke Luke's gonna like snap out of his
shit and be like I've gotta go back I've
got a you know but then she just was
like yeah what why did you even me I
guess you just had to knock her out for
a bit but am I giving this better wake
her out that was I'm kind of yeah that
was a huge tease for the audience
because I think the audience thought
particularly the Carrie Fisher god now
that they're like yeah which is it like
she's in the rest of the movie I'm yeah
I am very good given a very prominent
part it just creeped me out a little too
because I'm like she's dead yeah when he
see her floating and he's dead it's like
floating frozen corpse and it really
looks like a frozen corpse just like I'm
conscious again and I'm just like she
makes that sound - yeah I mean I'm like
I'm very curious if maybe they had this
scene all done before she died and
there's like well I guess we'll keep it
but I just
I'm not saying it felt it appropriate
like just felt very weird yeah that
she's dead and just her flying bag was
very odd so but I'm not sure I hated it
as much as you but I'm like I get where
you're coming from I'm like I don't know
how to feel about it and I gotta think
about that just I don't know there's a
whole ride home I was like even tonight
like it's about her passing away
it just feels silly and that's saying a
lot given stars and space wizards dumped
on like this just say about her it's
basically like if she didn't do that
weird pose maybe it would have worked
but pose could you do that would look
dignified carry Fisher - I don't know
what karate kids I thought she was gonna
vanish into thin air in outer space like
that nobody she actually like - I
thought that was it um so twist I don't
like that I think not like that so ray
unless they screw around in the third
film and makeup rather than the edge I
did kind of like the idea I was like
that's right you're a nobody and I'm
like thank God you know finally there's
no connection
there's no I'm not hundred percent yet I
will see what happens I I honestly would
kind of before there be will cos like it
was like well everybody show her parents
leaving away and her as a kid and it
like why would they build up all she's
my feels all just my companies don't
really seem to be built I know
everybody's interconnect there is this
but we forget who the fuck was Anakin he
was some piece of shit slave on a desert
planet what's in the mirror and say who
are my parents and she sees herself I'm
like is it another Anakin where she just
popped out well that's kind of what I'm
thinking because it seems to me they
keep implying that with this now the
prequels are canon so we're fucked
but you know if if that's canon then I'm
like well if you want to adhere to can
and then she could be the next virgin
birth to counteract Ben you know they do
make some references to the prequels not
many but okay so I did thank God when
she's like but what is the force grad
was like if luke says it's mini chlorine
so I was gonna be like fuck you dude and
the person that comes back is Yoda and
at first one I saw
I went oh no I can't do they but like
that word seconds it won me over cuz I
think I go back to a puppet it really
looks like a puppet but he looks like
he's there and it still count looks like
he's alive no light Luke is so Luke is a
weird mixture of Kenobi and Yoda in this
film did you notice that he's got the
trickster part of Yoda down he's like
get outta here like there's a part that
seems kind of a little light-hearted in
the others but there's a very super
serious part that brooding kenobi like
no rabbit laser so down a father's
throat it's the only civilized way like
you know it but Yoda he gets so
seriously these I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna burn it to the ground and and Yoda
just so light-hearted I'm showing him
the way and just saying you know like as
if it's really fucking matters which
yeah any sages really just kind of like
that like you could have pulled it off I
thought now is Zen texts where it's just
like the words are meaningless
absolutely 100% my favorite scene in the
scene where I thought oh no are we doing
this turned out to be my absolute fan
that the line said he says the way he
acts don't start hitting him on the head
when they both just sit down and look at
the the fire going and stuff and see the
back of their heads I mean just like wow
this this feels like this is exactly
where we should be beside exactly what
should and I feel like you have just had
that feeling and it kind of nail live
just like I've been written for this for
a long he's seeing all the the insanity
this shit is cause like maybe it's time
to start over a bit like okay here's the
other thing too it's like cuz you know I
I forget that they're like you know that
they're the dead masters they're the
spirits are there to help guy you to you
in the spirits they help you when he
just waves his hand and I'm like okay
spirits you reach see what shit you're
good boy
I mean that's but again it kind of ties
into because you see what Luke does at
the end which again it evolves the force
like it actually takes a pass that's
okay let's evolve this to another cuddle
I'm wondering for a while why they don't
do that where he does the astral
projection thing and I'm like well if
you can do that from the spirit realm
can you do that I'm getting now why he
does it because it's like an apparently
killed him like used up all his energy
but what and then here's another thing
too and again this surprisingly very
intelligently ties into the sequels
prequels remember how at the end of
Revenge of the Sith
you know Yoda is talking that you know
we're dissing whatever his name is you
know has found a way to come back in
spirit like what gin and tonic
yeah I mean like heat like what like
this has never happened before someone
has come back so at the end of that like
the force has evolved you know from
great master and here at the end of this
one it is evolved as well with what Luke
could do at the end but it's not so far
removed beyond reality of the world
where you're like no that could never
happen it's like if there's anyone that
could do it it would be luke at this
stage like everything feels like that's
that that could happen well any I you
know it also seems like he's sitting on
some sort of he's sitting on the Jedi
equivalent of a dozer building it seems
like like this is just some sort of
portal gay like you know all sorts of
energies concentrated here so I I liked
that um you know a part of me wonders if
he's gonna die anyway if you know you
could have just brought him to the plan
and Adam do it but that that whole
battle was no because everyone have been
able to do oh man probably yeah oh
that's that's true because he did yeah
yeah I love Ben and he's still standing
that's a good point
um and that whole scene that hi Dan dog
okay so here's the scene I had to double
check of him bloody he gives
Leia the dice from the Millennium Falcon
I'm pretty sure it's what that was and
then when Ren comes in he looks at me
and they disappear too so there's just a
strange part of me saying okay he has to
use all his energies
literally killing him to go and and
fight kylo Ren and put off this uh you
know this illusion and then when he has
to physically be on time okay make sure
the tanks are still there makeup always
moving this company sure the things are
still there make sure the tanks are
still there just back of his head is he
just thinking that done the dice were a
focal point duck the dice are the key
[Laughter]
you know when you put it like that you
jackass don't ruin the movie for me um
no you know what something else just
Ponton but the total I did the twist I
had no I just felt like this just
obvious like you know it's like and now
strike ray down and I'm like and he
kills Snoke I was like very like going
into it I felt like he's gonna kill
Snoke that's the only way unless they
have the balls to either turn raid to
the dark side and she kills both of them
were joins us I was almost hoping she
was gonna join up with he was but I'm
like nah they they didn't if they did
they've been building up enough yeah I
would do but a part of me was kept
because it was getting so challenging
that was like that would be the ultimate
challenge now how do you watch this as
Ray becomes dark side to like it was
like that became but here's my other
issue though with Snoke
I'm besides the name smoking jacket yes
is that okay so again we're in spoiler
this dudes dead he gets killed off
doesn't really do much what do you think
about it um you know just Surya says
build another empire they do it that's
about it but okay so he gets killed off
and but there's this whole backstory
it's like you know Luke this training I
could feel the d'Arnaud guess snow gets
already gotten to him snow did this no
and I'm just like now that you did this
guy I know I took the selfie I'm just
like okay we'll never know where this
guy came for how he got to know Cal
already know Luke did it and I'm usually
like the mystery is more powerful but
now that he's
dead oh yeah what this as well and
that's the problem is the mystery would
be more powerful like the mystery is
more powerful worked with Palpatine all
these stupid names yeah I worked with
Palpatine because you didn't see him in
Star Wars he was just reference to the
end of the Empire you barely saw him an
empire it was just that that one clip
and then he's finally revealed on the
third one there's this aura of mystery
and scariness around him it's like when
you left you didn't think who was this
guy you just thought well that was the
Emperor like it's terrifying that was
fucking tempering this one from the very
beginning it's like who's this guy's
talking to he's referenced all the time
and then then this one is like yeah they
kill him off and it was like oh this guy
no okay here's my big problem is that
you know you got Han Solo son you know
that the the the son that you know of
this guy is you know sister and he's
training him and just smoke got him it's
like well how did Snoke know you
literally like a sentence or two would
be fine I don't need much just something
to connect me somehow how did he know
snow Kelley there's no snow this was my
lightsaber buddy's did they drink at Mos
Eisley it's like how did this my problem
with the Abrams movie they gave you no
context or backstory it was the one
glaring thing more than the callbacks
like the callbacks I'm like all right
they're callbacks whatever it was just
more the way I felt like little
connection to what was going on they
blow up the Republic's headquarters or
something I'm like what's that the
Republic headquarters yeah what's going
on here there was a whole subplot with
Leia's attending going to try to beg
like how this system was working where
it's like how can there be a resistance
if there's a republic and there's a new
like it never gave the backstory for
that and then we never get a back story
with Snoke unless they're saving that
for the third film I mean maybe a baby
out in the third film it'd be impressive
see how they do that now that he's dead
but you would have to flashback which is
only rogue one is the only one that's
done that there's been no flashbacks
I guess there's been brief flashbacks
and force awakens yeah but but not much
yeah
so any other spoilers the little furry
things are are not the worst but they're
yeah
they're just toys they have a purpose
what you think they are it's exactly
what they are it's not just one of them
there's a ton of them I don't know
that's better or worse they literally
display the price it costed yeah like
Leia finally gets her damn hug or Chewie
finally gets his damn hi-yah who gave a
fuck yeah
seriously like I still hear about that
shit like who Kublai I'm like the Rob
did Han still shoot first at cynicism
port this is so that's way more
important if you argue this moral
character yeah and I feel like the way
they did it would just like Chewie
I've just like every what yeah like
somebody with it they were just like
yeah a diver um Laura Dern I didn't like
her what do you think like she has an
awful way that she just seen this cast I
think she was miscast I never felt like
she could commit yeah she didn't feel
like good general she's like you know oh
my mate when they when that's not like
an angry mother talking about alright
look we are very soccer mom ish um okay
like there's no authority kind of when
it kind of boat the the blasters or
whatever I just felt like how did this
not happen even earlier cuz I just like
there I felt like there was a vote of
no-confidence I can't I have no pride if
I tell them the plan it's like a ha you
see we're trying to do Polly was all
there was no reason to keep this feel
like way is like because Poe you needed
to learn a valuable yeah it's a you
learn a lesson later yeah no little
things like that are kind of dumb but I
feel like they're not awful they're just
like little look at that cool they way
that go but yeah and I mean that's like
a problem it's hard to compare it to
Empire because Empire had them on the
run and it was always this constant
chase the chase here is this war of
attrition with this really slow-moving
cruiser and this really slow-moving
started it would keep cutting back like
it's like you know it's too far out of
range
well then just go a little fast like
well if we can go to lights bein we have
tons of fuel while we just go a little
less than light speed to catch one
wonder is why you couldn't just light
speed ahead like the four feet or
whether I don't know how the mechanics
of it works maybe better than this by
the way are wonderful yeah and no and
the final show that cruise it was like
when they hyperspace through their thing
I always wonder why somebody who's ever
did that violates their was just the
silence was great everybody was just
like wow yeah that was great the cutting
kylo Ren a knife or no cutting of smells
good I miss that
cutting Snoke and half and then when
when she and when Ray and kylo join up
like I'm calling it we started that
there were like three other applause
moments and we didn't start those but
I'm calling that one that was the first
big applause moment in breaking that was
again just pure nitpicking but you got
all these ninja red guys who really suck
at protecting the river guys many they
really suck at protecting their
Emperor's awful at their jobs they
bother after about five of them go down
Ivan figure the last three would be like
you know what no okay guys get there in
the big ship and everything just you
know they all go down but sending like a
million stormtroopers okay Emperor's
dead yeah
get your asses in here I mean but know
what something like no we got we're
ready
Jedi lightsaber ninjas her I just why
are they bothering if Supreme Leader
Snoke is dead hey Rey the wicked in
Fuhrer's deed I just kind of way yeah I
want to go like Wizard of Oz's
you cute I just white
I feel like okay at first maybe they did
but when when it's just like the last
three of them left
i I just if I were on those red guys I'd
be like I'm good like you want it good
then just paint this outfit yellow cuz
I'm out of here I'm fine
so yeah I think the only the only twist
that got me was just the fact that there
was no twist with ray it's just no
parents are trash yeah yeah I don't know
hoping that's it cuz it's like I get it
I like the idea of somebody just coming
from nowhere and they're like you don't
have to be related from great this is a
battle but so why are you building that
up so much though I don't know like they
were really building that up well I
think maybe who is it who are they who
and I'm just like it might be McGovern
if they if they don't do it they don't
do it if they do do it if they do it
then there's a juxtaposition between Ben
cuz we're gonna lose Leia that seems
certain there's a juxtaposition between
Ben as the last of this Skywalker
fucking dynasty that started with
asshole Anakin and now you've got just
this complete newcomer not related to
anybody you know comes out of nowhere
it's a nice it's a nice you know I
finally be like she represents literally
the fresh start
gotta left field no I'd be lying if I
said I didn't kind of like that too but
it's like there's so much build-up to
you know is something I realized because
they they built this thing this island
has you know it has the light side as
the dark side is two sides Avery
Schwartz and there's a and there's this
hole and she goes into you know the hole
and she sees and all these mirrors and
stuff I was thinking to myself of it
didn't seem to her guys she just sees a
mirror and she snaps is that let's see
my parents it was myself
oh it just felt so empty and alone and
stuff I was thinking like well why was
that so terrible and I realized some
from her it would be no no no no no see
I realized something else apart from you
know that she doesn't like that burns
for nobodies and abandoned her and stuff
but that you know what are the the Jedi
and as you got Luke and you got Yoda and
said they're literally setting the past
on fire let it die no that's done we
have our nagua and she's searching for
the answer no I gotta know I have to and
she's out trying to by ourselves
has no answers into all she seizes
herself she's the new start so basically
for somebody wants all of these answers
and Luke do this for me Luke does it I
want to become Jedi and like she goes
down than today cave and all she sees as
a reflection of her Sam again but this
is a heavy sighs she's the fresh start
which would be terrifying and again this
is this war talking about with rhymes in
repeating okay that scene kind of rhymes
and Empire Strikes Back when he fights
Vader in that dark area and he sees
himself in invaders mask uh repeating
would be there's kylo Ren she kills him
and it turns out it's her as kylo Ren
that would be repeating a rhyme is a
similar idea where you're searching for
something it's a dark place and you see
yourself but he can represent yeah in
else case an infinite reflection ever
said that she is all there is not yet Oh
Luke is or Vader is Luke's father or
that killing him would be like it's like
leary all she sees is herself an
infinite reflection yeah that leaves
basically to the end which just leads to
another mirror which is inflection of
yourself so it's a similar idea but it's
not the exact same be ever beat you know
thing and awakens take notes yes stupid
lines like all right so it's bigger how
do we do yeah I'm just like you just
admitted you're doing the same thing
again but but again I as I send this
down a great review I get a little bit
more why they did it it's to set it up
okay we can do this now we're gonna take
this in new territory but it's still
it's still familiar but I also like new
and it's dar warm I feel like this is
knocking for us a week like what force
awakens built as if to say well we'll
continue this on same path this knocks
force awakens down and says pulls the
rug out from under us some of the
familiarity and says like you thought it
was gonna be all just the same thing I
might meet again yeah but I ironically
like how Empire Strikes Back do to see
again is that right it's not repeated it
is right but it's so funny that we're
quoting Lucas so much on that but this
one I think at one point he knew what he
was yeah he's the one who said special
effects are just a tool no you know but
here's what happened to that guy here's
the other thing too when you hear men
interviews and stuff like that he is a
smart guy he's a very eloquent guy in he
is usually very good words and don't
like wrecked yeah so I feel like there
is still value to be had from him
definitely I mean that sounds bad I had
no idea what the guy it's like he could
be super super sweet who's gonna give
like all the money he made from when I
talk about that I mean like you know
artistically and stuff and it's like
even bet it's like that's very cruel I
don't know this person he could be a
super sweet and super nice I see he
seems hurry this weed a nice what I'm
saying is that there's many things that
he can say that you know okay so he
directed you know movies that we don't
like that's connected to his property he
can there's still a lot of great things
he can say and do and you know every
person has been I mean since we're in
spoiler even not just the way it's
different and is tearing down force
awakens but even the things it
referenced I mean freaking Snoke says
himself she could barely carry a
lightsaber and defeated you you know
you're conflicted like it's referencing
things that happen in force awakens that
people have problems wouldn't say no
this is part of the story he sucks it
what he does yeah and there's a reason
because he's conflicted um you know so
it you know they seem to acknowledge
that it's like who the fuck is this she
came out of nowhere
and that's so weird that people have a
problem with that because I'm like well
that's what Anakin did well I suppose
people like war Anakin either but if you
would executed that properly I doubt
anybody would have given us salutes just
as the direction was so bad in the
prequel I moved at first you know it
seemed to come nowhere you are boys
smart ahead of this but you know okay
when you were watching that movie for
the first time you're saying well he's
nobody sir I don't understand this it's
like no it's still awesome that he does
all this it's like it's cool it's so
farm boy that comes from nowhere and he
fucking blows out the bad guy I mean
yeah it's cool no Luke
way more complex character because as a
farm boy who was able to bull's-eyes
some fucking rats on his desert planet
he was able to defeat his ace pilot dad
from the Clone Wars who's a Dark Master
the force and blow up the Death Star
after receiving like 20 minutes of Jedi
training with a wiffle ball but he's not
a Gary Stu no other other weird question
who those weird nurses on his Island
like every once a while like I think I
think I've had prayed to this and I just
think of little details I'm like what
was that there the lizard nuns of course
no I swear to God like instagrams like I
know exactly what these are the nuns of
the monastery who are taking care of the
place and their lizards for some reason
I didn't like him I didn't like him that
much I mean I always know it can get
worse so it's like I can't be to me but
I'm always like yeah it was weird it's
like I think it's just the I think this
grand epic thing and I just think I like
these little details like yeah what was
that I feel like I'm guessing more of
those as I watch it more about gonna be
so blindsided by how big and huge and
emotionally oh everything it's a
legitimate problem with the film because
there were moments that took me out of
the epicness when they would get a
little too goofy yeah like that so it's
good like that yeah mines those lines
wink just when he sees three Piggin
Mostyn Luke I love that Winky gave him
you know as he walked by I was like it
just seemed like a Luke thing to do like
you know I liked him talking to artoo
again and like a lot of Mark Hamill's
comedic bits I thought really worked
yeah I mean we the Joker I think he'd be
really good at the county oh well you
feel yeah that's the force pitch field
of courtship no and and the other twist
that I kind of saw coming it's like huge
Freud's cue me I'm like yeah like I kind
of figured that's where they were going
with that like Luke is not being
completely honest and oh yeah I he tried
to take the first shot kind of I didn't
know about that either that felt so like
oh what a coincidence at the minute like
he was just thinking for a second maybe
I should kill know that oh that's an
awful
and then he just happened to wake up and
see him in that exact moment no you
don't understand which granted how do
you explain that I was gonna kill you
now where Mark Hamill was telling this
guy like I disagree with it every single
thing you're doing but I will do it like
cuz he's got to be protective of this
character and this is not a very kind
movie to Luke Skywalker like he he comes
across as like I ran away I was gonna
kind of kill this kid I had second
thoughts but now I created this guy I
don't want to train you I go even see my
fucking sister like it's he's definitely
a very jaded more bitter character but
but but it's your managing I like that
for she's like okay this is not the head
but then you also think about you know
the wisest most beloved Jedi Yoda he did
that to oh yes I mean it's something
where it's like again he's kind of right
but it's like but he's not Yoda he is
Luke yeah so what's this schmuck okay
yes I mean I don't know I really feel
like I like talking about these
characters like well that's kind of like
what this person did you know but you
see how that would rub off on them how
that would happen it's like talking like
real people crimes
yeah no it's I really think that's a
perfect way to put this it doesn't
repeat it rhymes and they're good rhymes
they're very very good right I feel like
definitely at the end of this trilogy
we're gonna be done like these nine
movies it's just like that's it whatever
happens from now on is separate from you
know well they said they want to do
another three well no no no but but I
feel like that other three is gonna be
fresh yeah not like that to Luke and Han
and like not sure will be connected to
like Rey and Finn and stuff I mean I am
but it's like the whole the whole
Skywalker yeah this movie was about just
burying the past yeah kylo Scissors
there to bury the past I was like I feel
like they're all mine like they're
almost talking to Disney and themselves
like we need to bury this shit we've had
the prequels we've had the the original
three of it we're gonna have to make it
fresh and do something different this is
all about killing it it's one of those
big move on it's that beautiful
convenience where it makes sense to the
story and make
says from a marketing standpoint yeah so
wait which 10 now be on a roll with yeah
yeah max we're coming for you
yeah me I'm gonna feel sad when you know
the mouse buys us and you know whips us
to watch it's gonna be like that scene
in the Blues how much girl oh I need
that company's a monitor yeah but
they're very entertaining right now I
feel like I want to all my like after
the news today I kind of want to hate
them yeah cuz I'm just like Jesus are
you just gonna run the world but I'm
just like I can't I don't hate this
movie like now there's shit they've done
that I did not like beating the beasts I
hate it's it mostly it remakes I hate so
yeah but this is pretty salad that's
right
fork it over yeah keep it comin I'll
watch him this is really really good
it's as much as we can about this go go
see yourself your own you're on a big
season minion I'll say yeah it is a
challenge is this will be one more
people are just like I didn't like it
I'm like I'll get this way more than
other Star Wars ohms would be like I
could like I could see how you weren't
liking like you did
fucks with your head a little um it
definitely is not I guess what
characters that you so yeah oh and I'll
boy though we don't know grown to want
to believe the happily ever after Ewok
ending we want to you know and this just
is not that yeah so um but I'm very much
ok with that - I like you would not be
seeing more Star Wars movies No so I
feel like most people that I do feel I
feel I feel this though I think this
will be like for some people that have
been on the fence after force awakens
this is gonna be the make-or-break
moment cuz if you're like hey Joe now
I'm like they're gonna be like that's
Joe enough to the third one and I would
get that cuz like this one is where you
gotta look in and be like
and this is where we left with these
characters is not what I imagined the
night I'm like and I'm not gonna watch
the third one or this is challenging and
I may have issues with it but you know
it kind of surprised me and want to see
what they do with it so yeah this won me
over I'm now you know we're the first
ones like okay well I mean that's a lot
reapeat but man are we gonna do this
again is this next I'm just gonna be
Empire and its really won me over and
I'm really excited it was the two towers
I guess because two towers got me really
excited for Lord of the Rings and then
that just really hyped me up for Return
of the King you know and yeah I'm sure
the Kings kind of the best of them so
we'll see what that yeah maybe everyone
knows maybe this maybe I'll be this
series like the third way actually be
the best yeah maybe good yeah so but I
just see I don't know where you go yeah
me too I like gone and like Leia they're
gonna have to kill so I'm obviously the
complex gonna be between rancor yeah you
know but yeah that's everything else I'm
kinda like yeah but but I like that I
like that I don't kill afraid kills kylo
Ren becomes a dark Empress herself and
then the new trilogy starts over trying
to defeat her would be something and
then it's like you know yeah it's like
you know finish who was the hero of the
whole time and you know the main hero
now you have oh my you could have done
more with her no you knew who this she's
can't survive that no she can I'm gonna
bet you with that I will bet you money
right now I will throw down money that
she will come back with a scarred face
I'll burn to a crisp like it on bitch
it's gonna happen you know it I both do
and don't want to see that yeah you do
yeah as stupid as it is yeah you do so
yep that's about it
go see further man it's great yeah I get
nothing
why did this stupid joke Rob it comes
full circle like Star Wars no it didn't
it right you know what it's it did come
full circle it's bullshit
it rhymes Jar Jar is the key shut that
door
you